well the challenges of the past year
have really taken a significant toll on
our kids especially when it comes to
their mental health
so the clark county school district held
a forum with experts tonight to talk
about the issue of student suicides
orco mana joining us now live with more
on what they talked about orca
well denise and brian ccsd says that 23
students
have lost their lives to suicide in the
past year
the number before that for the year
before was nine
to address this crisis the district
enlisted the help of experts
who say it really all boils down to
getting everyone involved
it's been very difficult for her karina
singer says her 8th grade daughter selma
has had a tough time
since distance learning began she's just
very lonely she said very
sad she pretty much stays in her room
all day and doesn't really do anything
karina says thankfully selma doesn't
have any suicidal thoughts but suicide
among clark county students is a concern
the district saying 23 students have
died by suicide since march 2020.
suicide is not a choice mental health
experts joining ccsc leaders monday
night to discuss how to tackle the issue
one way is through the columbia protocol
a series of simple but pointed questions
to assess someone's risk of suicide the
columbia protocol
is the ultimate see something say
something to
help prevent suicide state leaders agree
having the right tools is key
to be able to detect and intervene when
an individual is suffering
is really the best way to go so with
ccsd implementing the columbia protocol
are you working on providing teachers
these sheets we're going to start
looking at the next steps is how to
how do we get those out through our
schools and not just in our in our
classrooms in our schools but
in our departments one parent who lost
his son to suicide also stressing the
importance of openness
to make it okay to talk about it
mainly if you're having one of them
suicide days
that's something karina plans to do i'm
definitely going to continue the
conversation
now if you or someone you know is
struggling you can call the national
suicide prevention lifeline
that's the number there on your screen
800-273-8255 and advocates are also
pushing
for more reform when it comes to mental
health and suicides among students
that includes more funding for school
counselors reporting live in the
newsroom tonight orco mana 8 news now